Анатолій з дівчиною замість відпустки в Парижі залишилися на валізах посеред аеропорту Бориспіль.
Іспанський лоукостер скасував їхній рейс в останній момент.
Ми запланували собі маленьку відпустку, присвячену Дню святого Валентина на пару днів у Париж.
Ми брали квитки, ми забронювали готель, все було добре, ми приїхали в аеропорт
і тільки що на стійці я дізнався, що у нас рейс відмінили через "нестабільну політичну ситуацію в Україні".
Схожа ситуація і у Тетяни з Ростиславом.
Скасування рейсу авіакомпанія не пояснила, утім, про причину пара здогадується.
Нічого не кажуть, не зрозуміло, чому скасували.
Мабуть, через ситуацію, яка відбувається на кордоні, а там хтозна.
Наразі більшість рейсів і в Борисполі, і в решті українських аеропортів таки курсують за розкладом.
Попри те, що днями українську авіацію почало лихоманити.
Спершу США, Британія, Японія, Південна Корея і десятки європейських країн
закликали своїх громадян поїхати з України.
Згодом захвилювалися міжнародні страхові компанії -
оголосили, що можуть припинити страхувати польоти над Україною.
Мовляв, ризики надто високі. Експерти таке рішення оцінюють неоднозначно.
Це досить унікальна ситуація.
Чим вона викликана - може бути багато різних факторів.
Як політичний, так і внутрішні ризики, які ми маємо розуміти.
Після збиття того самого Боїнга МН-17, після втрати українського літака в Ірані
багато і авіакомпаній, і компаній оцінки бізнесу переглянули свої процедури з точки зору аналізу ризиків безпеки.
Вони стали значно вищими, тобто компанії реагують набагато раніше, реагують набагато жорсткіше.
Так нідерландська компанія KLM першою призупинила польоти в Київ,
уникати повітряного простору над Україною вирішили і Норвезькі авіалінії.
Перевізник SkyUp заявив, що призупинить продаж квитків.
Водночас компанії-власники літаків, які надають судна в лізинг авіаперевізникам,
зажадали, аби їхній транспорт залишив Україну.
Як наслідок, частину флоту МАУ довелося відправити в Європу,
а український перевізник Bees Airline  взагалі залишився без літаків - довелося домовлятися про нову оренду.
Однак за лічені дні буря в українському небі вляглася на тлі новин про очікувану деескалацію і не без втручання держави.
Причому пасажирам, схоже, таки доведеться за це поплатитися.
Адже страхування літаків тепер коштуватиме дорожче, кажуть експерти, а отже, ціна авіаквитків може зрости.
Щоб небо над Україною залишалося відкритим, уряд виділив 16,6 мільярда гривень.
Ці гроші підуть компаніям-страхувальникам і власникам літаків.
Це дещо зменшило напругу, але не в усіх галузях економіки.
З найвідчутнішого для українців - курс гривні.
Останній тиждень був нервовим - гривня часом просідала до 29 за долар.
Економісти відзначають: йдеться про психологію.
Люди стали частіше купувати долари і знімати гроші з карток і депозитів.
А це тисне на національну валюту. З іншого боку, таке явище - не масове.
Трошки страшно. Деякі кошти знімали, про всяк випадок міняли валюту.
Поки що дома сидимо, нікуди не рухаємось.
Я помітив, що курс долара трохи піднявся, але не бачив, щоб аж так значно.
Ажіотажу біля банкоматів чи відділень банків я не спостерігаю, тобто, на мою думку, все більш-менш спокійно.
І все ж напруга на кордонах і в інформаційному полі б’є по українській скарбниці.
Про це у владі заявляли не раз.
Голова фракції "Слуга народу" Давид Арахамія навіть назвав конкретну суму -
2-3 мільярди доларів втрат щомісяця.
Експерти таку оцінку вважають дещо завищеною, але визнають: валютні коливання не минають безслідно.
Нацбанк вимушений продавати все більше і більше резервів.
Він купував, продавав, балансував цю історію на міжбанку, згладжував коливання.
І десь в нього негативне сальдо десь близько одного мільярда доларів.
Тобто реально втрати можна оцінити в таку суму.
Військова напруга і курс валют вплинули й на автомобілістів.
Пальне останніми тижнями невпинно росло в ціні.
За даними Мінекономіки, за два тижні кожен літр бензину А-95 здорожчав на 90 копійок.
Загроза російського вторгнення тут має вплив, але опосередкований - пояснюють експерти.
Росія є одним з найбільших експортерів нафти.
Пальне робиться з нафти.
Розуміння того, що в якийсь момент можуть початися військові дії в регіоні,
які не закінчаться за кілька днів перемогою, зрозуміло, що це потягнуло вгору ріст цін на енергоресурси.
Зважаючи на те, що поставки до нас також зав’язані на стабільність в регіоні.
Водночас, за прогнозами економістів, курс і ціни на пальне можуть незабаром повернутися до норми.
Але за умови спокою на кордонах і в новинах.
Курс гривні, думаю, відійде до позначки 27,5-28 за долар.
Враховуючи потенціал нашого експорту зернових, особливо у першому півріччі,
і ціни тримаються на високому рівні, і врожай був високим – серйозних загроз я не бачу.
І з перельотами, і з пальним за кілька тижнів усе стабілізується.
Якщо раптом цей наш сусід спробує щось додатково загострювати…
складно сказати, навряд чи це пряма агресія, але в нього є досить багато можливостей дестабілізувати роботу інфраструктури,
зменшувати наші можливості по закупівлі електроенергії,
дизпалива, палива і таке інше, то він може деякий час ще порозкачувати цю ситуацію,
і це може тривати і місяць і два, і три.
Принаймні загроза російського вторгнення підштовхнула Захід до більшої підтримки України.
Єврокомісія пропонує виділити Києву 1,2 мільярда євро макрофінансової допомоги.
США запропонували мільярд доларів кредитних гарантій.
Економічну допомогу Україні також пообіцяли надати Німеччина, Франція і Великобританія.
Щоправда, в обмін на реформи, які на тлі можливої ескалації на сході
відійшли на другий план у порядку денному української влади.